vous êtes ont fait c'est très gentiment
pendant toute l'émission parce que vous
êtes prêts à aller encore plus loin
non mais elles ont dit ah vous me suivez
j'ai dit est ce que tu es pêche par
orgueil
non
par avarice est-ce que je pèche par
avarice tenant par gourmandise
oui parents vous parle luxure non colère
oui paraissent non
est ce que tu crois en dieu non
je dis mon dieu n'est pas le dieu des
églises c'est lequel alors non ce jet
m'arrive de faire des prières
quand j'ai envie très forte quelque
chose arrive d'ailleurs s'arrête jamais
ces comportements peut-être croire en
dieu que ça aiderait est ce que je
trouvais toujours des prières avant le
gong qui induit indéfinissable qu'est-ce
qu'il est différent avec le dieu donc
parler les gens qui croient en dieu est
un dieu un dieu à qui je m'adresse quand
j'ai envie qu'ils mènent et qui m'a dit
on fait donc j'ai jamais dis que c'est
peut-être pas le bon là non j'aime bien
je lui remets pas en question